The next organization that we
will be looking at is similar to
distributed shared memory, except that
we are no longer sharing memory, so
it's called distributed memory.
No sharing of memory means that only
one core can access a memory slice,
and the others can not.
So what we now have is cores
that have their own caches, and
each of them has its own memory that
can only be locally accessed here.
So really, each of the cores pretty
much has what looks like a complete
single core computer system.
And a network interface card
that connects it to a network.
But now when a cork has a cache miss,
that cash miss goes
directly to this memory.
And if the core wants to
access something that is
in another core's memory.
It can not simply issue an access that
message in the cache and goes there.
Now what it needs to do is actually
create a network message using some sort
of a send primiative in the operating
system to actually send a request.
The program here needs to
receive that,see what is
being requested,respond to it and so on.
So now communication is explicit
it's no longer sufficient to simply
put data in memory and then another
core just reads it from there.
You have to actually send the data
explicitly to another core
if we want to communicate.
So.
That means that you write
programs differently from this.
Symmetric shared memory and
distributed share memory pass
data around using shared memory.
Meaning reads and writes to
memory are used to exchange data.
Now we are using what is called
message passing for communication.
So now you are pretty
much writing a program
as if these were independent machines
that communicate over a network.
If you have a distributed
memory supercomputer, for
example, it's just that this network and
these network cards are a lot faster
than your normal internet connection.
This type of a system is also called
a multicomputer because really each of
these is like a complete computer.
It has the processor, the cache,
the memory, thumb I/O, and
the processor only directly
accesses the local memory.
So it looks like complete
uniprocessor system.
These are also called cluster computers,
because really, you put a bunch of
normal computers together into
a tightly networked cluster, and
you get something like
a distributed memory system.
These types of computers tend to scale
to a large number of processors.
The reason is not that they're
fundamentally better at
communicating than
shared memory systems.
The reason is mainly that
the programmer is forced to explicitly
think about communication because you
use a different type of primitive to
communicate than you use to
access your local memory.
So the programmer is aware of
communication going on and
then naturally they will tend
to minimize communication.
And if at all possible,
access the local memory.
So this approach works better, primarily
because it forces the programmer.
To figure out things that
otherwise it might not notice.
Because it forces
the programmer to figure out
how to communicate efficiently.
Whereas in shared memory,
the programmer may not even realize
that some of the accesses are not local.
And thus are slow and causing
a lot of communication to happen.